we are following a developing story
metro police say they have new
information on the person suspected of
murdering las vegas reporter jeff
gearman now please take a look at your
screen police are looking for this
person dressed in an orange coat with a
wide tan sun hat and carrying a large
duffel bag mary jane bellies has been
chasing this story all day long mary
jane now has more
jeff gearman was found stabbed to death
outside his home in the northwest valley
saturday morning police say they believe
a fight led to german's death they say
it appears the person seen in these
photos was casing the area to commit
other crimes before the stabbing
happened rob langrill remembers his
former colleague as diligent and a
thorough writer he met german in 1996
while working at the las vegas sun in
the journalism industry he was
you know just recognized as a as a just
a top notch reporter and investigative
uh you know writer and
and researcher
you know it's it's
it it's a tough
time when you lose somebody you know
young steve sebelius the review
journal's politics and government editor
describes his colleagues death as
shocking sebelius first met german back
in 1993 and describes his friend as
ambitious and a self-starter jeff was he
did all the big stories there the big
investigations he had great sources and
and just an incredible job and so a lot
of the younger reporters you know were
kind of in his shadow there police say
the stabbing happened near vegas drive
and rock springs metro police are asking
people in that area to review their
cameras to see if they captured some
more video of the suspect we did speak
to some of german's neighbors and people
at a nearby park they say they didn't
see anything suspicious but offer their
condolences reporting from vegas drive
in rock springs mary jean valeza 8 news
now